[Musique]
bonsoir est heureux de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau 7,8 le journal voici les
titres de l'actualité
une trentaine de facteurs à l'appel de
la cgt étaient rassemblés ce matin
devant la permanence de benoît hamon
étape lui manifester contre la
réorganisation de leur temps de travail
nous étions sur place et puis hier soir
d'assurer des entrepreneurs avaient lieu
à versailles un concours était organisé
pour l'occasion neuf entreprises ont
participé pour tenter d'obtenir à chaque
de 10000 euros dans le cadre de notre
portrait de la semaine nous avons suivi
le quotidien de michel aubert avait été
linéaire reval le praticien de dernier
dans le département et ne trouve pas de
remplaçant
on l'a appris aujourd'hui les yvelinois
ont été généreux cette année pour cette
30e édition du téléthon
plus de deux millions d'euros c'est la
collecte finale dans le département les
fonds permettent entre autres de mettre
au point des traitements ou encore
d'aider les malades à réaliser leurs
projets de vie c'est un non catégorique
pour les facteurs rassemblés ce matin
devant la permanence de benoît hamon à
trappes
ils ont manifesté contre la
réorganisation de leur temps de travail
selon la cgt cet accord mettrait en
péril les conditions de travail des
facteurs
écoutez vincent fournier représentant
départemental de la cgt
ils veulent encore installer la pause
méridienne qui est aujourd'hui le
facteur en général ils travaillent par
exemple environ 7h 13h 30
et là en fait ils veulent instituer une
pause le midi
donc c'est finir plus tard
en plus que ça permet cette pause
méridienne c'est à la poste de gagner
les 20 minutes de pause qu'on a
aujourd'hui
rémunéré comprise en temps de travail
nous on considère pas qu'il ya un besoin
dans l'organisation parce que la poste
elle fait des bénéfices toujours plus
énormes en fait le bénéfice 2007 il
augmenté de 33% par rapport à 2015
on vous le disait dans les titres hier
soir la soirée des entrepreneurs a eu
lieu à versailles organisé par le club
des créateurs et entrepreneurs
le but était de mettre en lumière les
entreprises des yvelines et du plateau
de saclay pour cela rien de mieux qu'un
concours pour découvrir de nouveaux
talents
un reportage de patrick jacques de
dixmude plus d'une cinquantaine
d'entreprises ont envoyé leur
candidature pour participer au concours
du printemps des entrepreneurs au final
seuls neuf ont été sélectionnés parmi
elles l'entreprise my city express une
entreprise sans cire oise dirigée par
sylvain gibbons si on pouvait gagner le
chèque on serait ravis mais je dirais
déjà avoir un réseau qu'on parle de nous
qu'on soit présent
là par exemple au monde
sur l'interview c'est quelque chose qui
est très important pour nous donc l'idée
c'est de se faire connaître et tester
l'adhésion inscrits dans la catégorie
jeunes pousses à fertiliser l'enjeu
était de taille
à la clé un chèque de dix mille euros et
pour les gagner il faut séduire le
public
cent mille euros virtuels investi et
chaque personne pour investir ce qu'il
veut sur l'entreprise sur l'entreprise 2
sur l'entente +3 et l'entreprise qui
aura collecté le plus de son virtuel il
repartira quand même avec un chèque de
dix mille euros à vrai cette fois
finalement my city express est arrivée
troisième au concours
c'est une application versaillaise qui
l'emportent cycliques géolocalise des
activités de loisirs on continue nos
reportages autour de la semaine de la
presse
aujourd'hui direction la rédaction de
toutes les nouvelles créée en 1945
l'hebdomadaire sur une fois par semaine
les journalistes sont des localiers
travaillant tous dans les yvelines
nous avons suivi pendant quelques jours
l'un d'entre eux mélanie poker
de cette semaine thomas saint germain
m'avait parlé lui car lille avait évoqué
le statut de l'élu 10 heures chaque
mardi conférence est les sept
journalistes de la rédaction près par le
journal à venir toutes les nouvelles et
dans les kiosques chaque mercredi
l'hebdomadaire
pendant une semaine on détermine les
sujets et bien sûr on essaye de coller
au plus près de la réalité et de
l'actualité donc il ya des sujets qui
vont nécessairement peut-être prendre
plus d'ampleur
et bien sûr on s'adapte donc
quotidiennement à l'élaboration de sora
et ce jour là deux de ses journalistes
couvrent saint quentin en yvelines elle
l'un d'entre eux alexandre marque et
fait parler sa plume depuis 15 ans
occupe de tout ce qui se passe sur saint
quentin en yvelines
bref essayer d'être au courant de tout
ce qui se passe d'intéressant d'innovant
voilà pour les infos locales le sport
fait divers nous essayons d'être au
courant un peu tout ce qui se fait sur
le secteur bonjour à prémilhat le
reportage est un sujet d'annonce
alexandre rencontre deux membres
d'associations organisatrices d'un
festival à la maison de l'étudiant de
l'université
comment vous l'envisagez c'est un projet
culturel ouvert aux étudiants mais aussi
aux habitants de cinq ans au moins des
structures telles que souvent les gens
nous achète aussi pour avoir les
annonces de ce qui va se passer le
week-end donc aussi j'ai même envie de
dire on est même peut-être plus là plus
intérêt à faire de l' annonce que du
contenu
alexandre s'occupe de 6 à lui reportage
par semaine l'écriture du sujet peut se
faire le jour même ou le lendemain j'ai
pris j'ai pris des notes sur mon cahier
et puis donc je vais les relire je vais
essayer de construire mon article
faire une sorte de robin rédaction comme
une dissertation un peu en essayant le
organiser un peu mes idées et après je
vais écrire directement donc dans un
bloc un bloc texte et puis après je mets
tout mon forme je rajoute un titre
rajoute une légende pour un pour la
photo 1h d'écriture par article le lundi
le journal doit être bouclée on passe un
autre portrait de la semaine ils sont
les médecins de nos meilleurs amis
les vétérinaires un métier connue pour
son activité la plus classique mais dans
les zones rurales ces praticiens
interviennent aussi à la terme c'est le
cas dans les yvelines 2 michel aubert le
dernier docteur à pratiquer cette
activité dans le département et qui ne
trouvent pas de remplacement portrait
d'un vétérinaire rural
un reportage de nicolas kirillovitch
martin combien vous avez de nos brebis
et en plus le bleu des fonds normalement
doit faire 62 prise au son des prises de
sang par dizaines par centaines et même
par milliers presque quarante ans que
michel aubert va et vient dans les
fermes du sud yvelines
le temps passe la satisfaction et
l'épanouissement personnel sont intactes
soigner ou prévenir les maladies des
animaux
ce jour-là opération prophylaxie à la
ferme de grand maison située à chevreuse
tout le réseau soit on fait les unes
après les autres mais tubes sont guère
en jeu toujours dans le même ordre
là je sais que j'ai la première là c'est
la 39e
le numéro encore noté sur des feuilles
derrière donc on ne peut pas ce qu'on
peut dix pour cent intervention à la
campagne pour 90% en ville
progressivement la clientèle de michel
aubert a évolué une tendance de fond
devenue problématique depuis 2015 sa
quête d'un remplaçant français ou
étrangers se révèle veine ses clients
ruraux risque ainsi de se retrouver sans
solution dans quelques semaines
c'est au moins trois semaines par an on
aura bertone au niveau vétérinaire sais
pas comment on va faire là vraiment on
sait vraiment pas comment faire on
espère vraiment que monsieur robert là
va trouver un remplaçant technique
j'ai un autre élevage par exemple aux
états où il ya deux vaches là mon client
je suis venu il m'a demandé quelles sont
les solutions je suis pas je crois que
ça d'ailleurs des solutions serveurs de
vente de loges évolution des moeurs ou
des mentalités les jeunes vétérinaires
ne sont plus aussi disponibles que leurs
vignes séverac pourquoi il y aura qu il
serait temps de 5h et les libéraux frais
60 heures
c'est vrai qu'ils cherchent à conserver
un confort de vue peut-être catr j'ai
peut-être couple et des choses dans un
dommage ou sa vie michel aubert laura
dédié à parcourir les routes du sud
yvelines entre intervention à la ferme
ou en clinique à rambouillet trente huit
années passées au service des éleveurs
de la région et des clients qui sont
devenus avec le temps des amis pour mes
clients qui ont déjà trouvé une solution
je leur dit de toute façon vous avez
continué à me voir parce que moi je
continuais à venir pour pour le saluer
pour vous faites de la vente en direct
je vais continuer à venir acheter ma
viande je t'aimais je t'aime et yaourts
chez double donc ça va continuer
deux amis reste et si les amitiés reste
michel aubert qui tracy sur la clinique
et la médecine à la fin de l'année on
prend la direction de rambouillet où la
nuit de l'eau était organisé le week-end
dernier soutenir l'accès à l'eau potable
pour les enfants défavorisés d'haïti
c'est l'objectif de cet événement la
ville participait pour la cinquième
année
les détails de l'opération avec nicolas
landry apprendre à synchroniser ses
mouvements pour pagayer un exercice pas
si évident pour paul du haut de ses 6
ans il s'essaie au kayak en compagnie
d'une camarade de classe
fig et robien canoë kayak
samedi on a pu faire du canoë kayak une
belle initiation et pourquoi pas l'année
prochaine entrée au club et du
secourisme bien sûr apprendre les gestes
qui sauvent la pls et puis le massage
cardiaque
même pour des petites six ans et demi
c'est quand même extraordinaire de leur
enseigner ces gestes qui peuvent sauver
des vies plusieurs activités mises en
place par la fédération française de
natation
une dixième édition de la nuit de l'eau
au profit de l'unicef
cette année les fonds récoltés serviront
à soutenir l'accès à l'eau potable haïti
haïti qui vous le savez a été frappé par
un ouragan terrible en octobre dernier
l'ouragan matthews de nombreuses écoles
ont été détruites mais également tout le
réseau d'adduction d'eau a été endommagé
ses tantes et subir aujourd'hui bien les
les haïtiens et les enfants en
particulier n'ont pas un accès à une eau
de bonne qualité et en conséquence de
quoi attrape de plus en plus de maladies
aujourd'hui encore plus de six cent
mille enfants sont en difficulté à haïti
dans les yvelines quatre piscines ont
participé à l'événement ce type de
journée peut permettre de récolter 2000
euros par manifestation mais la
solidarité ne s'arrête pas à la fin de
la nuit de l'eau l'unicef continue de
récolter des dons pour haïti sur son
site internet
et puis le week-end dernier était aussi
organisée à coignières la 23e édition de
la fête de la bière
un orchestre bavarois a rythmé la soirée
au menu choucroute accompagné de vin
blanc
à consommer avec modération bien sûr des
festivités mises en place par le comité
des fêtes de la commune présidée par
jean armel catalan l'objectif de cette
soirée c'est vraiment de passer une fête
entre amis
et les amis en fait ils se retrouvent
dans au sein d'une amicale
ils se retrouvent aussi donc entre
voisins aller retour des habitants sont
bien sûr très très positif et c'est un
moment de convivialité et pour le bien
vivre ensemble au sein de petites
communes telles que la nôtre 1 et 4400
habitants
c'est ce sont toujours des fêtes qui
sont très très apprécié nos nous
administrer c'est la fin de ce cette ut
le journal merci de nous avoir suivis et
surtout bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]